en el corazón de la capital libanesa el
prestigioso museo xurxo que es uno de
los edificios tradicionales más dañados
por las explosiones en el puerto de
beirut
después de un cierre forzado de dos años
poco a poco está volviendo a la vida
la destrucción fue enorme después de las
explosiones sobre todo en el edificio
principal en el sótano y en las obras de
arte recibimos el apoyo de la fundación
ad lift y del ministerio de cultura
francés lo que nos permitió realizar
renovaciones
a cerca de un centenar de edificios
históricos resultaron dañados tras la
explosión en el puerto es el caso de
esta casa donde vive el padre y brian
cashman
a él le ayudaron a sus sesiones
especializadas en la restauración de
edificios patrimoniales y de
banco mi casa resultó muy afectada por
las explosiones del 4 de agosto estaba
inhabitable no había muros y el techo
dejaba pasar el agua
beirut de gini sheriff ha trabajado
durante tres meses para que en la medida
de lo posible la casa recupere su
carácter tradicional
las autoridades libanesas hicieron un
catastro de los daños unas semanas
después del desastre pero los
propietarios se quejan de que aún no han
recibido ninguna ayuda estatal
hace aproximadamente un año los
militares vinieron a inspeccionar las
instalaciones nos prometieron ayuda pero
fueron las asociaciones de la sociedad
civil las que realmente ayudaron con las
reparaciones
biophilia acta de lesión
pero evita iniciative y otras ongs han
logrado reparar el 30 por ciento de los
edificios históricos de beirut
el resto sigue destruido o inaccesible
en más de la mitad de los casos fueron
los propietarios quienes realizaron las
reparaciones en el resto fueron las
asociaciones que trabajaban en el
terreno incluida beirut harvey touch
iniciative las que hicieron el trabajo
para ello nos hemos asociado con otras
fundaciones la unesco por su parte
financió la rehabilitación de edificios
protegidos pertenecientes al estado